there is very one one woman you would
still date oh Sh
ish ish I'm not I'm not a hundred
percent its ish oh I thought you were
dead set that he was going to hand out
okay wait
I made a bet when I was in high school
so you have to imagine I'm living on a
farm in the middle of America right and
and really having no chance at having a
happy life and and I've sort of
succumbed to this so the best ideas I
have are like sitting around in
basements with my buddies making bets
about what we would do someday so what
and so I make a bet with my buddy I'm
probably 17 years old I say I said him
I'll bet you $1,000 that someday I will
go on a date with Jennifer Aniston I'm
17 years old nyah and she's like on my
screensaver on my computer at this rate
and and he's like you're on and someday
so you know four or five years later I
actually meet Jennifer Aniston and she's
married to Brad Pitt at the time and so
I I went to Brad Pitt and I asked him
permission to ask his wife listen I made
this bet with my buddy
God you got your cool guy you're gonna
let this go down right and he looks at
me he's like you go for it right and so
I asked her and she turned me down
and she I asked her I said listen I
asked permission from your husband he
said it's okay he said it's all fine I
just want to take you out for a pizza or
something and she's like I don't think
that's not a good idea I know and and so
it didn't happen but now we're friends
she was afraid of her feelings could've
been I think that's what it could have
but you didn't trust herself yeah love
the scale of your fantasies this is
reality nothing no it was reality that I
want to ask Janet Ellis from Blue Peter
right never happen
[Applause]
you know I've given up on it it stopped
for me romance when I was about 22 when
I I bought a girlfriend back from
college and my parents got really nice
garden and they were away so I thought
this is this is perfect we'll go and sit
in the garden I made you a picnic I took
some food not big nipples but hadn't
been introduced yeah in the Sun and it
was grass and Sun and one thing led to
another I love that I love that line she
was wearing it was really romantic I'd
only go into details I don't to make
anyone bring their pig nipples up but
she had a long flowing skirt and she sat
atop me things started to like a toilet
roll holder so she was there and it was
really romantic and the breeze and
lovely and and I thought well this is
awesome this is one of the most romantic
thing that's ever happened between two
people then my granddad came around the
corner honestly I'm not making about and
he's never met her before so he came
round about hello Yuto
she couldn't get off because it was
happening and you could see him thinking
she's really rude if some boats it's
really rude because I've never met her
before surely she should stand up she
couldn't so it was a full 15 minutes
Oh like this it's our dick lamm
in her my granddad making polite
conversation that was the day I gave up
on romance
[Music]
you